that's not the plan
I was going to say uh For You Blue uh
tell me what's the update with your
legal situation because we've all I mean
look we've been hearing about what
happened you obviously got out quick
guys
I'm on house arrest
um
hopefully my next court date I could be
off house arrest if we can come to an
agreement and you know come to an
understanding and
you know
um now is the origin of all this stuff
that whatever happened at that strip
club no so I got to attempt to murder
case and that's because it's all in
Vegas yeah yeah it's on Vegas so I got
to attempted murder case
and then um
maybe like a couple days before my court
date I came out here for my court date
and then I had gone into something at
this casino
where rock hit this girl and then I had
to like you know play defense and you
know it just got got carried away and
then so because of that incident they
put me on Outsource and told me I gotta
stay here wow
so all the all the the big the big the
attempted murder thing that's unresolved
yeah that's unresolved but I was still
dealing with I was still fighting and
going to court you know but once I went
to court for that case
they [__] booked me for that case
like they put like a weird warrant like
the day of right okay he's coming to
court here because like technically he
like didn't wasn't doing what they asked
of him to do the few days before so I
was gonna take so like when you got
picked up a couple weeks ago what was
was it a probation violation no it was
for the for the [__] at the casino but
he came out here for that but he
probably should have just came out of
type okay some civil right at the casino
so the next court date they like they
put a warrant that day yeah right
because what I did wasn't enough for
them to like Grant a real warrant go to
California and get me for me right right
right right right have you decided uh
whenever this all gets resolved you're
gonna just leave Vegas alone hell yeah
just go to the Morongo bro we just never
need to come like oh yeah if you want to
gamble just go to Paul yeah that's what
I said I like Bob's Rings like every
time you're in Vegas it's just bad I
only want to gamble no more I just want
to sit at home and make money I don't
want to go outside I want to go to no
bar no club or nothing I just want to
sit at home yo I mean you've obviously
obviously been dropping um I mean you
dropped the record where you were in the
jet ski in the pool was it called smile
didn't have been having okay um
how I mean you don't seem
too focused on putting out like a new
album or anything I mean he's just
dropping here and there but I don't know
I'm just
like I said at this point in my career I
want to get money with my significant
other right you know that's what I want
to do I don't want to get money
yeah yeah others you know whoever wants
to be my kid you know like I said I did
it for myself already yeah so it's like
look I did it for myself I did it for
rock now I have to do it it's like I'm
just reassuring myself you know yeah as
time's going on
um
I just saw recently maybe two days ago
she had a spill Krishan had a spill
she's pregnant with your with your child
she had a spill at the clubs she fell
off
um hey man I don't know I was just gonna
say that personally I don't think she
should be in the club this late in the
game I don't think she I thought she was
rolling up on Ice it's not about the
money it's not about now she just kind
of she just kind of lost in the
the hype of social media well I was
gonna say obviously you're she's
carrying your child that's your that's
your child right so how worried are you
about the safety of the womb the safety
of them I can't I can't worry until this
is it's on my plate you know right in
her belly when she has it I hope she
watches it wises up and like realize
that every penny is not worth
are you trying safety like like what's
the do you have you even put your mind
around the custody situation no no no
I'm gonna let her be a mom I'm Gonna
Hurt yeah try to be a mom and let her do
her best at it and then if she doesn't
succeed then I'll step in but
man [__] it's hard to push the baby all
right it hurts
it's more than that it hurts you you
spent nine months with a baby in you and
then you push it out it hurts it's like
kind of yo yo the ball's in your court I
feel like I mean the balls in the balls
and whoever's carrying the court I mean
whoever's carrying it from day one
though like I'm saying you as a mother
you carrying it you nurturing it when
you pushing it out it's on another story
a lot of the work you guys have two kids
together yeah a boy and a girl and I've
seen the whole process it's a lot of
work it looks very painful
and if you're going through that you you
gotta you gotta be down for that you
know yeah I was gonna say like if it
gets to the point where you're like I
got I gotta take care of the kids oh
yeah I'm gonna do what I have to do but
I'm gonna let her be your mom are you
babysitting
I'm not babysitting I'm not babysitting
no she's not babysitting but yeah
I don't know she's responsible yeah I'm
yes I'm a responsible human being
absolutely but I I mean I'm not a
babysitter either
I I think that it's something that they
or he needs to figure out I don't know I
don't really have a good figure I don't
really have a say so that's the least of
my words I'm hoping that she does a good
job and once it comes out she changed
her State of Mind is she still signed to
you no uh no because she was kind of
like your artist the way I see it is
when you start doing business without me
it's none of my business you know what I
mean
right